[Music]
hello dear friends welcome to the
program i'd like to know i trust that
you're having a wonderful day
being blessed abundantly by the lord
amen this is a question and answer
program
where
the
those who watch our program send us
questions
uh questions that they might have about
different aspects of scripture
and we do the research we try to find
answers and if we are able to find an
answer we share it with you on the air
if you want to send us a question
we have an email address that you can
send them to
it'll be on the screen tv at some tv dot
org
once again tv
at some tv dot org
and we will be glad to do the research
and provide an answer if we can find one
obviously there are mysteries in the
bible
don't ask us how god could incarnate
christ into the human race because
that's a mystery but if it doesn't
involve a mystery we'll tax ourselves to
the utmost to try and find an answer for
you so please send us your questions i
have with me daniel miranda who is in
charge of our spanish programming here
at secrets unsealed
he also does a lot in english as you've
been able to see he preaches sermons for
our sabbath morning service
he does symposiums there are many things
that that he does here his wife kelly
works here as well um they're doing a
phenomenal work and we appreciate having
you and not only on this program but at
secrets unsealed amen for me it's a
privilege and a blessing to be here
praise the lord would you have a word of
prayer as we begin of course let's pray
dear heavenly father
thank you for this program
thank you for your word that is a lamp
into our feet and a light and to our
lives
what would we do without your word
and we thank you because we can find
answers to the questions in your
inspired writings and i pray lord that
you may guide us into this study that we
are going to have in the name of jesus
amen amen
you know we have a question uh pastor
miranda that i don't think i've ever
heard anyone ask yeah this is the first
question yeah
what what is the question
so the question is
is from a person that
is single
is in his 30s
and says is there a place for single
individuals in the church
like people who decided not to get
married
despite their age or individuals who
have already committed to being single
for the rest of their lives and this
person here shares
that is receiving a lot of prayer uh
pressure from
his church members because they are
telling him that he needs to get married
or else he cannot
be
useful
for the church
so he asked if there is a place for
single individuals
in the church
well celibacy is not a sin that's right
we don't have any that in the bible
uh if if that were the case then jesus
would be the first sinner
he was single good point and john the
baptist was single we have paul what was
single although some people argue about
that
because if he was part of the of the
sanhedrin then he needed to be married
yeah uh well i answer
that uh ellen white tells us that the
reason why he was he became part of this
unhindered was the part that he played
in the stoning of stephen so they really
liked this guy they
saw him as a good asset for their cause
and he was called to be part of the
sanhedrin but anyways that's not the
point in this question
being single is not a scene it's not bad
there are some
benefits there are some advantages and
also some
disadvantages
is it wrong to one
to stay single
it's not wrong no jesus said it
in matthew 19
verses 11 and 12
there are three types of
single people
or celebrates
um
or eunuchs i would say
unix yeah enochs yeah that's the word
matthew 19 verses 11
and 12.
well actually from verse from verse
uh jesus is warning in the previous
verses about sexual immorality
uh about adultery and then his disciples
said to him if such is the case of the
man with his wife it is better not to
marry
[Laughter]
now the lord this is very difficult it's
a high standard
he said to them
all cannot accept this saying
but only those to whom it has been given
what's saying about you know marrying
for there are eunuchs who were born thus
from their mother's womb
and there are eunuchs who were made
eunuchs by men that's the case of daniel
and there are eunuchs who have made
themselves eunuchs for the kingdom of
heaven he who is able to accept it
let him accept it so
some have the gift
some become eunuchs by force
and some willingly
become eunuchs in either case
it is not wrong jesus says all who can
accept it or who all who can take it as
the king james says let him take it
those who
have the gift
and
don't feel like this person i don't feel
alone because i am unmarried and this
person this person actually feels happy
about it
maybe this person has the gift of
celibacy
so my counsel would be don't let those
people get to you yes
you know there's nothing sinful nothing
wrong in being single and you know when
when it says there in luke matthew
chapter 19
that there are eunuchs because of the
kingdom of heaven for the kingdom of
heaven
the apostle paul would probably fit in
that category he would you know what
would it be like for paul to be married
and to be traveling all the time you
know
marriage requires a lot of work
it requires a lot of effort
you know you have to share your time and
and your work with someone else
so some individuals decide that they
want to dedicate
themselves totally and completely to the
lord's work which would be detrimental
if they were if they're married because
their wives would never see them correct
and so
you know
being single is not sinful if god has
called someone to be single for the
cause of the kingdom of heaven to be
able to dedicate full time to the
ministry more power to them amen
okay i hope that that's comforting for
this person who wrote to us
what what's the next question that we
have
next question
is also anonymous it says
why advent why the seventh-day adventist
church does not ordain women to pastoral
ministry and however ordain female
elders
are not the same verses stating men of
only one woman implicit for both
ordinations
with all the respect
that looks at theological hypocrisy
no offense my beloved brethren
so this person doesn't see any harmony
with
we say not to ordain women to pastoral
ministry
but uh we ordain female elders yeah and
the person is right right
because uh
the same applies to elders as well right
there there's a contradiction in
practice in practice is what there is
because
um you know the church has authorized
the ordination of women elders
but it has not authorized the ordination
of women pastors
and uh and it has been authorized in
annual council i believe right yeah i
just want to give a little bit of the
history in the 1975 spring meeting
which is kind of like
like the fall council except there are
less people that attend the spring
meeting and usually they're mostly from
north america
in the spring meeting of 1975
it was authorized to
to ordain women elders in
extreme circumstances in north
america
not not because any uh of any biblical
council
but because there was a complaint that
there were certain districts where there
were no men who could minister and
therefore you know be necessary to
ordain women elders to to officiate the
lord's supper and so on
but that was mainly north america it was
north america's request
then in 1984 the fall council
authorized the ordination of women
elders
on a global scale
but with severe restrictions
i don't have the restrictions here but
you know if you go if you go to google
you'll be able to find
you know certain restrictions there had
to be agreement between the church and
the conference had to go through a
process in other words
and
it was authorized globally but the
problem is that this issue was never
actually taken to a world session
you know normally
if in 1984
it was discussed about women elders
it would have been taken to the general
conference session the next year because
usually you know the fall council sets
the agenda basically for the general
conference session the next year
but it wasn't taken to the general
session in 1985
and it has never been taken to a general
conference session the ordination of
women elders
so basically it's a decision made by
annual council
that has not been approved by the world
church
and that's a problem
because
because the the supreme authority of the
church is the general conference session
and so it should have been taken to the
general conference session in 1985 you
know the the idea or the request to
ordain women elders but it was never
taken to this day
so it becomes a problem because clearly
the bible says that the elder needs to
be the husband of one wife
and
you know why the wife is not the husband
of one wife
and so basically the church has
authorized something that scripture
does not approve
and and we are in a quagmire now in the
seventh adventist church because of this
particular issue now i would like to
recommend
that
those who are really interested in this
particular topic
we produce a lot of material in the
course of two or three years here at
secrets unsealed on this issue of
women's ordination
leading up to the san antonio general
conference session
and i would recommend that you access
those materials i wrote many newsletter
articles during that period we also
produced two symposiums on all of the
different issues relating to women's
ordination
and
you know if you're really interested in
this topic and you should be interested
in this topic
check out those materials and then make
up your decision as to whether you're
going to follow what scripture teaches
or whether we're simply going to
establish standards that are not
approved
by scripture so you know in synthesis
that's a short
answer to this question the person is
right uh you know you you can't uh say
okay we'll ordain women elders but we
won't ordain women as pastors because
it's the same ordination basically
you know the it's interesting that the
passages
that
speak about the ordination of elders are
the ones that are read at the ordination
of pastors
so that's an evidence that that it's the
same
basically function the only difference
is that that the local elder who is
ordained he has is authorized to
minister in the local church
whereas uh a pastor who is ordained
is authorized with the ministerial
credential credential to minister on a
global scale in any church all over the
world so the local elder is simply local
whereas the minister who is ordained can
minister on a global scale is authorized
and i think soon the church will have to
make a decision of this discrepancy
either
to completely ordain women or to
stop ordaining women elders yeah because
that argument is being used
okay if it doesn't make sense we already
ordained women elders
why not
uh women pastors yeah and
and recently some of these comments came
up in the last the recent uh general
conference session
when the wording of the church manual
was actually changed
to be in harmony with this previous boat
by the an annual council to ordain women
elders yeah it was more generic right
well they actually wanted to uh make the
pronouns gender neutral
okay yeah uh so so that uh you know it
could apply to a male or
could apply to a female
my personal opinion is and this is only
my personal opinion
is that we're too far down the road to
reverse the ordination of women elders
because basically it's become a global
practice yeah so i don't see the church
anytime soon anyway
re reversing
you know the by by a general conference
session the ordination of women elders
which i agree with you eventually will
lead to the authorization of the
ordination of women pastors
and
you know which is contrary to scripture
but uh
you know god god allows of the church
freedom to do things like we see in the
history of the jewish nation
and then the church has to suffer the
consequences for not following what god
says in his holy word right
uh so anyway that's a short answer to
this question check out all the
materials that we have uh you know you
can go we everything that we have is now
available on our app
everything we've ever done
you can access on our app so i would
encourage people to do that
okay we have another question that comes
in
and this one is very interesting i
hadn't thought about this
but
let me just read it and then you can
open
i am andrea scobee from trinidad west
indies i listen to many of your
presentations and enjoy them thoroughly
thank god for what he has been
accomplishing through you and the team
as i listen to the revelation series i
learned very much
however there is one observation which i
tend to see a little differently
it has to do with the symbols and
language of the book of revelation
you and other preachers say that john
borrowed most of them from the old
testament
and in some instances verbatim
but this is how i see this phenomenon
john is taking off and describing what
he was shown
since this information is much the same
as was delivered by other prophets and
they are taking of the same things
the imagery would naturally be similar
also like the book of daniel where the
pattern was repeated with amplification
what john is describing would naturally
link with the past
and certainly there are expansions
he could not give different pictures or
symbols because he corroborates with the
truths already told
to me this proves authenticity
also since jesus was giving his messages
for the churches as a good teacher the
greatest he would start with the known
and lead them into the unknown what do
you think about these thoughts i would
appreciate if you could direct
respond direct to this email rather than
by waiting to have a question answered
on air since i checked on youtube
many of the questions are answered
you know by by kelly
in spanish uh we have larry pyburn who
answers many questions in english
and uh but uh you know we're doing this
um in order
according to the way that we receive
them and we're doing that on television
so what can we say about this you know
it's interesting i think this uh this uh
per this lady has a as a point yeah i
think she does
um
i would like to refer you all to first
corinthians 14 32 and uh
i'll try to give my answer based on the
principle we find in this text
first corinthians 14 32 it says and the
spirits of the prophets are subject to
the prophets
so what that what is this saying this is
saying first of all the prophets don't
contradict themselves
and this is also saying that
a later prophet builds on a previous
prophet and they don't the the spirit of
the prophets are subject to the prophets
now when we say because i have also said
it
that
revelation borrows from imagery from the
old testament and ellen y herself says
it as well
when we say that
we are not saying that this is dependent
on the wisdom of the prophet
right it's the holy spirit that actually
borrows and takes material from the old
testament
and reveals it to the prophet and the
prophet rise it in his own words
as god has shown him or showed her
so
why does god this because he wants to
build up on previously revealed
knowledge through previous prophets uh
in his word this is a way of sending us
back to the old testament to study more
i think
louise ware has a principle on this he
calls it multo imparbo
so he doesn't have to for example
john doesn't have to write the whole
story of elijah
to make a point right but he mentions
uh jezebel and that is enough to see
that implied you have a aha aka ahab you
have uh elijah you have the false
prophets right and now we have to go
back to the old testament study the
entire story right and then see how it
fits in the context of the book of
revelation right if the book of
revelation included the entire story it
would be an encyclopedia yes
i think what's happening here is
that the
safe let's take for a practical example
ezekiel chapter 9 that speaks about the
seal that is put on the forehead
it's very obvious that that's in the
backdrop of revelation 7 the seal of god
placed on the forehead
the whole the holy spirit gave that
information to ezekiel
right
and so and so what happens is the holy
spirit gave the information to ezekiel
and then later on the same holy spirit
gives the information to john john
but there's still a link
between
the book of ezekiel and the book of
revelation on that particular point you
have the song of moses and the lamb
well you know you have to go back to
exodus chapter 15 where you have the
song of moses to understand the song of
moses and the lamb uh the same holy
spirit that uh
that had uh
you know the recording of exodus 15
which is the song
is the same spirit that uses the
expression song of moses and the lamb in
the book of revelation so
i don't think that
when we say that the book of revelation
draws much on the old testament is wrong
because the same spirit that gave it in
the old testament is once again giving
it to john in the book of revelation
yeah ellen white says that in revelation
all the books of the ma of the bible
meet and end acts of the apostles page
585. okay
it's a very phenomenal chapter on the on
the book of revelation a general
introduction to the book of revelation
so anyway i i appreciate the thought you
know i can tell that this uh this lady
is a thinker is a thinker andrea and
she's got a point
that
you know that because in the new
testament you have the same basic
content
uh it's an evidence it's a confirmation
that the holy spirit is leading in both
testaments that's right
all right the next question is very
interesting
can you please help me understand who
the father of leah and rachel is
then there's a letter a in the bible in
the following verses
beth well is referred to as their father
and then puts genesis 22 23 genesis 24
letter b
in genesis 24 29 laban is referred to as
rebecca's brother
why then is laban referred to as their
father in ellen white the story of
redemption pages 89 and 91
i'm confused
so please clarify the confusion
well i perceive that there is a
there is a confusion here between
rebecca and rachel
because
genesis that even the same verse that
the person is using genesis 22
22 23
clearly says that
um
it says and bethuel begot rebecca it
doesn't say begot rachel
yeah these ate
milka
abraham's brother
so bethuel
was rebecca's father
and he also had an another son
that
he called laban
laban was ray rebecca's brother okay as
we will see laban was rebecca's brother
bethel was their father
and now when we go to genesis 29
and then this is this is the difference
here johannes genesis 29 versus
five
and
six
it says then he said to them this is
jacob do you know layman the son the son
of nehor
and they said we know him so he said to
them is he well and they said
he is well and he looked
his daughter rachel is coming with the
sheep so rachel is whose daughter
labans
and
who's the father of laban
we saw here beth well so that's what is
the grandfather
how do we know that laban is rebecca's
brother well in genesis
24 29 that the person here also quotes
uh
clearly laban is rebecca's brother yeah
so i think that solves the confusion i
think so and you know many times in the
bible
the word father is used in the sense of
ancestor
uh you know for example when daniel goes
before belchazer
he says your father nebuchadnezzar well
he was he was uh nebuchadnezzar was his
grandfather correct but it's
it's used in the sense of uh
ancestor
okay so i hope that that helps
um
it's a technical question and we have
just a couple of minutes left let's see
if we can cover this what's your view on
the timing of the edges of the sabbath
according to leviticus 23 32 from
evening until evening having in mind the
different time zones and also long day
short time periods how can we all be
certain of the time when the sabbath
begins especially the days when it's
past 6 pm but the sun has has not yet
set and vice versa
what's the problem for a divine defined
zone to use 6 p.m to avoid all these
discrepancies
well actually
um
the church in its early years
the after
starting about the sabbath they had the
position about 6 p.m that had been
proposed by joseph bates and even ellen
y embraced it
but then god corrects ellen white and
shows her no andrews has the right
position right uh it's actually from
evening to evening actually even the
sunset that's that's the word so with
that principle in mind that it's not 6
pm but it's the sunset so you use that
to do your different time zone
and where the sunset is that's when the
sabbath begins yeah it's very simple
yeah i mean
sunset is not
the same for everybody all over the
world exactly you know the sab the
sabbath comes to
us in other words when the sun goes down
that's when the sabbath is kept at that
particular place other places they might
have kept the sabbath before
and other places keep it after but all
of them keep it according to when the
sun sets correct
and so
i don't think that establishing a 6 pm
arbitrary date
for everywhere
would necessarily be
recommendable in the light of the fact
that the bible clearly says
that it's from sundown to sundown from
evening till evening shall you keep your
sabbath is what god says in leviticus 23
verse 30 right and in northern
hemispheres or southern hemispheres when
the sun in the summer barely sets for
example and in the winter barely
appears then that uh in the summer will
be the darkest point that would be
sunset right and in the
in the winter would be the
when the clearest point is fading right
right so so there is a way even in the
north pole right
to observe the sabbath according to the
sunset exactly well folks our time has
flown by
uh and our program is about to come to
an end thank you so much for these
questions we have a pile of questions
more
and we trust that you will continue to
tune in send us your questions please
and we will do everything possible to
answer them god bless you until next
time we'll see you
[Music]
you